para analizar este partidazo es un
placer para mí saludar a sara castro
directora del diario 'as' colombia la
bienvenida a las jóvenas noches tal como
decía en las declaraciones es un partido
de golf es así que interesante estar
esta noche hablando de esto como han
conseguido estos dos equipos llegar a un
nivel tan alto del fútbol y sobre todo
espectáculo yo no diría hola
distribuiría en tres puntos lo primero
es la convicción total en una idea ambos
quieren dominar el juego desde el
dominio de las opciones de llegar de
hacer daño al rival ahogándolo eso es lo
primero lo segundo es una evolución y
trabajo táctico muy muy muy juiciosa y
sobre todo trabajada y esto que tiene
que ver con el orden en primera
instancia pero también contarle a esos
jugadores muy técnicos la libertad para
que en los últimos en el último tercio
de la cancha puedan ser decisivos y
luego es esta yo diría que esa
estimulación intelectual que se produce
cuando se encuentran dos astros de la
dirección técnica como son klopp y
guardiola si usted mira las estadísticas
son ocho triunfos para club ocho
triunfos para guardiola y siete empates
esto habla de como ellos trabajan los
partidos muy bien para entender cuándo
van a recibir golpes cuando los van a
dar pero sobre todo es que cuando
hablamos de fútbol ofensivo también hay
variantes ahí lo de club es un juego más
directo más de hacer daño el otro el de
guardiola es más de la posesión un poco
más trabajado y con más tiempos pero que
buscan lo mismo buscan siempre dominar
busquen siempre o gara el rival y lo que
vimos hoy fue eso un fútbol con dos
conceptos muy importantes en la
actualidad que son la precisión y la
intensidad son partidos que siempre
están digamos jugándose no hay tiempos
muertos que siempre los futbolistas
están muy concentrados porque son esas
jugadas las que definen y termina con
estos resultados tan digamos cerrados
nos hace preguntarse que en sudamérica
jugamos el mismo deporte o ese es otro
deporte el que juegan allí esos